[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كانت القضيه الفلسطينيه وما زالت
تشكل نقطه الارتكاز في الوعي العربي
السياسي الحديث ولد الناس على فلسطين
محتله وعاشوا على مواجهات طويله وداميه
وسيل من الشهداء لم يتوقف يوما ولم يتوقف
معه صمود الفلسطيني وايمانه ومواجهته
الشرسه والمعزوله لابشع احتلال عرفته
البشريه في العصر الحديث كانت البدايه مع
حركات المقاومه الوطنيه المعبر عنها
بتيارات يساريه وقوميه الطابع والانتماء
والمرجعيه ثم ما لبثت البندقيه ان تحولت
ليد الحركات الاسلاميه واصبحت المواجهه
على قدر اكبر من التعقيد والقوه والتوازن
كما شاهدنا في الحروب التي شنتها اسرائيل
على قطاع غزه خلال العقدين اللذين انتقلت
فيهما مراكز القوه والسيطره في غزه لصالح
حركه الحماس والجهاد الاسلامي وفي الحلقه
الثانيه مع الدكتور خليل الحيه عض مكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس ورئيسي مكتب العلاقات
العربيه والاسلاميه فيها نقرا في تاريخ
وواقع هذا الصراع نستشرف افاقه المستقبليه
وما سينتج عنه في ظل واقع عربي واقليمي
متشضي واختلال واضح في موازين القوه
وانهيار كبير في المراكز العربيه لا يخفى
على احد في غير بلد عربي ايها الاخوه
والاخوات خليل الحيه ضيف المقابله في
الجزء الثاني فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
خليل الحقيقه نائب في المجلس التشريعي
الفلسطيني عن حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه
حماس وعضو المكتب السياسي للحركه ونائب
رئيسها في غزه من مواليد غزه عام 1960
تلقى تعليمه الابتدائي وانهى دراسته
الثانويه في مدرسه يافا
ثم حصل على درجه البكالوريوس من كليه اصول
الدين في الجامعه الاسلاميه بغزه تابعه
الدراسات العليا في السنه وعلوم الحديث في
جامعه القران الكريم والعلوم الاسلاميه في
السودان حيث تحصل منها على شهاده
الدكتوراه عام 1997
انضم ونشط في صفوف الحركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه حماس وتعرض بدايه التسعينيات
القرن الماضي للاعتقال لمده تزيد على
ثلاثه اعوام
انتخب عضوا بالمكتب السياسي للحركه وفاز
بعضويه رابطه علماء فلسطين خاب الانتخابات
التشريعيه الفلسطينيه عام 2006 على قوائم
الحركه في غزه وفاز بعضويه المجلس
التشريعي الذي تراس فيه كتله الحركه
لعب دورا محوريا في تحقيق التهدئه مع
الاحتلال في قطاع غزه خلال حربين 2012 و
2014 بصفته ممثلا لحركه حماس نجا من
العديد من محاولات الاغتيال واستشهد
خلالها سبعه من افراد عائلته عام 2007
حياكم الله دكتور سعداء جدا بوجودك في
المقابله
والسعداء بان نتحدث حديث مطول
حول الدكتور خليل حول نشاته حياته تعليمه
وكذلك المسيره السياسيه
والنضاليه والعمل المقاوم بشكل عام يبدو
ان القياده اليوم في حماس هو الجيل الذي
ولد ما بين النكبه وما بين النكزه انت
مواليد 1960 صحيح هذا هو الجيل اللي عايش
الفترات المخدره ما في تاريخ الشعب
الفلسطيني الحديث ذكرنا بغزه في الستينات
حيث نشات طفلا دكتور انت من غزه نفسها
اللاجئين
وعائلتي
انا شات في هذه الفتره وكانت منقسمه نصفين
نصفها الاول كانت تحت الاداره المصريه
وانا بالفتره الاولى المرحله الاولى
الابتدائيه اخذت الصف الاول الابتدائي
مصري مصري ثم كانت نكسه السبعه وستين وما
زلت اذكر حتى الان دخول الجيش المصري واق
بالبيوت ولانه كان احد اعمامي علي رحمه
الله عليه كان ضمن الفدائيين الفلسطينيين
وكان على الحدود ولما دخلت المعركه واذا
بالجيش الاسرائيلي مباشره يقتحم علينا
البيت وعلى النساء وعلى الاطفال
ويبحث عن فالذاكره سجلت منذ لحظات اولى
هذا الجيش المعتدي المحتل وصولا عند باب
المنزل وداخل المنزل ما زلت اذكر في ذلك
الوقت اقتياد والدي رحمه الله عليه واحد
اعمامي الى السجن في اليوم الاول من
الاقتحام الاحتلال واقتادوه من السجون الى
السجن وهم يبحثوا عن عن عمي لكن طبعا كان
قدر الله عز وجل ان يخرجوا من قطاع غزه مع
من خرجوا ووصل سالما خارج الحدود فهذه
الفتره هي فتره معاناه ثم بعد ذلك كانت
فتره اقتحام الجيش
والاغلاقات وحظر التجوال مع بعض ال 67
واللي كانت بوادر المقاومه الفلسطينيه
من جديد والمناجز كانت اما في الدخل
والخارج هذه كانت فتره كانت في صبانا لكن
ما زال في ماثل في اذهاننا سطوه وجبروت
وظلم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه مع تحامل البيوت مع الحصار مع
التضيق الى ان وصلت فتره السبعينات وكان
هناك مرحله جديده في الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
انه فتح الابواب وفتح العمل داخل الخط
الاخضر حتى في محاوله للالهاء الشباب
الفلسطيني عن المقاومه وانحداها عن هذا
التكدس لكن هذه كانت مرحله هي مرحله تمهيد
وتجديد لربما لفتره السبعينيات في مقاومه
جديده يعني وصل ذروتها لعند اكتوبر 73
مازلنا نذكرها ونذكر اقتحام الجيش المصري
وكيف عادت للامه للحق يعني ونحن في اوائل
حياتنا عادت الى الاعتبار التكبير
بالانتصار واقتحام الجيش المصري خط بر ثم
صوره نصر احدثتها الامه بعد نكسه نكسه 67
ففتره السبعينيات بلا شك كان العمل
للمقاومه الفلسطيني الفدائي وجود المقاومه
في لبنان بعد خروجها من من الاردن ثم بعد
ذلك تشكيل المجموعات فلسطينيه الاقتحام
التي كانت تدخل من الداخل الخارج وكان في
في مقاومه داخل القطاع غزه والفدائيين من
جيراننا واقاربنا وهنا هناك في كل يوم
عمليه هنا وهناك فكانت هذه مرحله مهمه في
تاريخ النضال الفلسطيني هذه الفتره كانت
ايضا فتره تشكلت فيها الشخصيه فتره النهوض
الاسلاميات اسرتي هي اسره محافظه يعني
تميل الى التدين بسيطه لكن الجذور
المقاومه في الاسره من اعمامي
وبعض اخوتي بعد ذلك كانت ممتده مع الجيران
اللي حولنا ثم احنا دخلنا في اطار العمل
النضالي مباشره ان كان في متابعه
ما يحدث في لبنان او عبر الحدود او عبر
العمليات او باعتقال اننا اعتقلت مبكرا
قلت في سنه الثمانين تعليم دكتور كان في
مدارس غزه كلها تعليم الابتدائي والمتوسط
والثانوي يمكن تعليم مباشره ابتدائي
والثاني ومن قبل الاعدادي حتى الجامعيه
الاولى البكالوريوس الجامعه الاسلاميه انا
اخذتها في غزه كامله يعني كانت في علوم
الشريعه نعم انا كنت في دخلت كليه اصول
الدين في الجامعه الاسلاميه والمناسبه
الجامعه الاسلاميه يعني درست المنهج
الاسلامي في العلوم الاسلاميه على طريقه
المنهج الوسطي مسترشده
بمدرسه الازهر يعني احنا في السنوات
الاولى كان ما يدرس في الازهر يدرس عندنا
ان كان في الكليات الشرعيه او كان في
العلوم العامه المتطلبات الجامعيه التي
كان يدرس فيها طلاب الجامعه بشكل عام
بعدين انتقلت عدد الاردن لدراسه سناتي لها
لكن لدي ضيفه ايضا ينافسك يا دكتور هو
الشيخ عبد الرحمن حياك الله يا عبد الرحمن
هذا حفيدكم عبد الرحمن وهي ذاكره اهلا
وسهلا كيف الحال عبد الرحمن ابن الشهيد
اسامه هذا حفيدي اللي هو احب واعز احفادي
على قلبي عبد الرحمن ابن الشهيد اسامه
خليل الحيه الذي يعني كان مع ابيه في ليله
استشهاده لكن والده واخوته الثلاثه وامه
استشهدوا ونجوا وكان عمره ثلاث سنوات
2014 مع اخته وجدته كان عمرك ثلاث سنوات
يا عبد الرحمن عرفنا عليك يا عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]
اذكروا اللحظه التي حدثت في استشهد فيها
والدكم واعمامك في 2014 كنت ثلاث سنوات
ماذا يعني لك هذا الشيء
الاحتلال الصهيوني متى يستسلم الفلسطيني
لماذا
نفعل كل ما بوسنا لكي
نرفع راياتنا ما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن
يعني هذه الحاله النضاليه البطولية
تلقائيه وعلى الفطره ما شاء الله تبارك
الرحمن
انتقلت للاردن بعد بعد اولا
انا في بعد
تخرج من الجامعه الاسلاميه وبالمناسبه
الجامعه الاسلاميه بدات في 78 كنا اول
دفعه من امن الطلاب وتخرجت فيها 83 في
مطلع ال84 عينت فيها معيد في الجامعه
الاسلاميه ومكثت حتى 86 في 86 بتعت لاكمال
الدراسات العليا للماجستير في الجامعه
الاردنيه في كليه الشريعه
وانهيت دراستي في 89 وعدت الى القطاع
وكانت الانتفاضه موجوده وعدنا الى التدريس
في الجامعه وانخرطنا في صفوف الانتفاضه
الاولى في الاعمال التنظيميه والحركيه
سنفصل في في هذه المسيره ان شاء الله اردت
ان من حديث عبد الرحمن لانه كان دائما
هناك حديث ان ان ربما حماس وحركات
المقاومه تقود سكان القطاع الى الى الى
التهلكه والى الى الى حياه صعبه لكن يبدو
ان هذا الامر هو رغبه اهالي القطاع وهي
المواجهه التي خذنا الناس من اجل استعاده
حقهم بالكامل اردت ان اسمع صوت عبد الرحمن
هو هذا
شبل فلسطين فقد عائلته لكن هو ينظر الى
الحياه بكل امل هو ينظر لنا الاحتلال هو
الذي اغتصب منه البسمه واغتصب منه الوطن
واغتصب منه اعز ما يملك ابويه لكن هو يعيش
في ظروف هو وكل الشعب الفلسطيني اعلم ان
ينزاح هذا الاحتلال ولكن حتى ينزاح هذا
الاحتلال الكل يدرك ان هناك اثمان لابد
انت ان تدفع عبد الرحمن ماذا تريد ان تصبح
اذا كبرت
بارك الله فيك دكتور سعيد جدا
ونستفاد نستمر في حديثنا طاوله الحوار
اهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]
في انعطافه وصفت بالاستراتيجيه اعلنت حركه
حماس عام 2017 قبولها قيامه دوله فلسطينيه
على حدود عام 67 الخطوه التي عدت تعديلا
جوهريا في البرنامج السياسي لحماس قيل
انذاك انها تقدم نموذجا عن انفتاح الحركه
على التعامل مع الواقع ورغم تمسكها بعدم
الاعتراف بشرعيه الاحتلال والتمسك بكل شبر
من الارض رات الحركه ان اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه على حدود 67 يعد صيغه وطنيه
توافقيه مشتركه التعديل جاء على النقيض من
الميثاق الاول لحماس والذي دعا الى تدمير
اسرائيل واقامه الدوله على تراب فلسطين
التاريخيه الميثاق الذي صدر في اغسطس من
عام 88 جاء بعد اشهر قليله من تاسيس
الحركه استنادا الى فكر جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وبالتزامن مع ذروه انغماسها في
احداث الانتفاضه الاولى
الميثاق ذاته رفض الانضمام لمنظمه التحرير
انطلاقا من اعتبارات ايدولوجيه صرفه قبل
ان تتجاوز حماس مضمون خطابها عبر التحالف
مع مجموعه فصائل بينها كيانات ماركسيه ضمن
التجمع رافض لاتفاق اوسلو لاحقا لم تعد
المساله الهيدروجيه حاضره في علاقه الحركه
الاسلاميه بمنظمه التحرير بل انتهت تماما
وفق ما جاء في اعلان القاهره عام 2005
تغيير من نوع اخر كان له تاثير جوهري على
مسيره حماس تمثل في فوزها بالانتخابات
التشريعيه عام 2006 وتولي اداره قطاع غزه
لتبدا بعدها حقبه مليئه بضغوط وتحديات
الحصار العربي والضربات الاسرائيليه
المتلاحقه ومن ثم انهيار الربيع العربي
وسقوط مشروع الاسلام السياسي بالضربه
القاضيه ما شكل مقدمه لتغير ملحوظ في
عقيده حما السياسي فانت انهيت الجامعه
الدراسه الجامعيه في مطلع الثمانينات
وعيونتها معيدا
متى كان انضمامك طبعا الحركه نشات بعد ذلك
بشكل رسمي لكنها كانت موجوده قبل ذلك هل
كان في عمل سياسي انتماء كامل ام ماذا كان
عليه الوضع يعني انا يعني
بديت التدين في المباشر في مطلع في وسط
السبعينيه كان عمري 15 سنه
والتزمت في المساجد التزاما قويا ومضيت
حتى دخلت الجامعه
ويمكن اول اول اللقاء كان شرفت بلقاء
الشيخ احمد ياسين رحمه الله عليه في يمكن
مارس 2080 كنت
1980 كنت قد خرجت من السجن في السجن الاول
والتقينا مع الشيخ احمد ياسين وكان قد اسس
في ذلك الوقت الكتله الاسلاميه في الجامعه
الاسلاميه وكنا في ذلك الوقت 15 طالبا هنا
نتحدث عن الاخوان المسلمين ما قبل نشات
حماس فكانت هذه الكتله الاسلاميه التي
تتبع للحركه الاسلاميه في ذلك الوقت وكان
في ذلك اليوم قال انتم النواه الاولى
للكتله الاسلاميه في الجامعه وبدينا ننطلق
في هذه الاعمال حتى
بعد هذه السنه يمكن ان اذكر في نهايه 82
مطلعه 83 تقريبا
انا كنت شرفت بالانضمام للحركه الاسلاميه
على يد الشيخ احمد ياسين رحمه الله عليه
وجلست معه لعده شهور منفردا في اشخاص
تثقيفي تنظيري حركي حتى انضممت لهذه
الحركه وبعد ذلك يعني انا اعتبر نفسي اني
منضم الى الحركه الاسلاميه قبل اربعين
عاما من من مجايلك من قاده حماس الحاليين
اليوم
ممن عاشوا في هذه الفتره معنا الاستاذ
اسماعيل هنيه استاذيح السنوار المهندس
روحي مشتهى
وعدد اخر يعني ممكن يكبرنا في السن زي
نزار عوض الله متقدم عنا في هذا المرحله
في القياده الحركه في غزه اليوم الدكتور
محمود الزهار اكبر منا لكن تزامنا بعد ذلك
في التدريس في الجامعه ثم في قياده الحركه
في اقول في 83 يعني قبل اربعين عاما
انضممت للحركه الاسلاميه في هذا الوقت 83
ثم بدات في المرحله الحركيه والتنظيميه
وشاهدت وشاركت في البدايات الاولى
للعمل المنظم الامني الذي قامت به الحركه
الاسلاميه في بدايه الثمانينات ما
العناوين الرئيسيه دكتور التي كانت تحكم
العمل الحركه الاسلاميه في تلك خاصه انه
من فتره السبعينات بدانا نشهد انتقال دخول
الخراط الحركات الاسلاميه في العمل
العسكري المقاوم شيئا فشيئا انتهاء باعلان
حركتها ماس وتراجع الحركه الوطنيه ايضا
اليساريه والقوميه الى حد انت تعلم ان
الحركه الاسلاميه في السبعينات اعاده الى
التشكل والظهور وترتيب اوراقها مع الصحوه
الاسلاميه في مطلع الثمانينيات بدات في
الجامعات في الجامعات الفلسطينيه كان يغلب
على ذلك الطابع اللي هو النقابي العمل
الطلابي العمل الحركي التنظيمي العمل
الشعبي والاغاثي بشكل كبير والعمل التنظيي
الداخلي والعمل الدعوي وانا كنت اذكر انه
في ذلك الوقت انا كنت خطيب وداعيه في
المساجد وامام لمسجد يعني من بدايه
الثمانينات وخاصه خريج كلياتها كليه شرعيه
فكنت اماما لمسجد وخطيب في المساجد هذا
المسار الدعوي نعم انا اخذت هذا صار
بالاضافه للعمل التنظيمي المباشر داخل اطر
الحركه الاسلاميه وتقلت وتطورت في عمل
التنظيمي والحلقات التنظيميه مباشره
والعمل الاعمال الاخرى فكنا في الكتله
الاسلاميه وفي مجلس طلاب الجامعه
الاسلاميه كنت في 81 ثم بعد ذلك في مطلع
يعني في 86 كنت عندما كنت معيدا في
الجامعه كنت نائب رئيس نقابه العاملين في
الجامعه الاسلاميه في ذلك الوقت كان يغلب
هذا هو العمل
للحل للحركه الاسلاميه
عندما بدات الحركه تميل الى العمل العسكري
وقد اخذ قرار العمل العسكري في مواجهه
الاحتلال في مطلع الثمانينات بدا العمل في
العمل الامني بشكل كبير تثقيف وترتيب
وتاطير مجموعات داخليه للعمل الامني
للمحافظه على المجتمع الفلسطيني من تغول
الاحتلال والاختراق الصهيوني وكف
تغول وتدخل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في المجتمع الفلسطيني
عملت في المسار الامني دكتور كنت في
المجموعات الاولى التي تشكلت تقريبا في 84
في هذا المكان كان عمل امني وكان هناك عمل
اخر ان المجموعات العسكريه التي قادها
الشيخ احمد يسير رحمه الله عليه واعتقل
على اثرها في 84 85 وافرج عنه لاحقا
استمرينا في هذا العمل 86 في العمل
التنظيمي والدعوي والحركي وهذا العملي حتى
خرجت استكمال دراستك يعني كان واضح انه
ثمه التحضير لمشرو ان المشروع يعني يتشكل
شيئا فشيئا للفتره القادمه على كل
المسارات الحركه الاسلاميه في مطلع
الثمانينات اعمالها الحركيه والتنظيميه
والمجتمعيه اخذت وبرزت الحركه الاسلاميه
مع الحركه الوطنيه في انتفاضه المساجد هذا
اذكر في 82 كان ما يسمى بانتفاضه المساجد
عندما كان اشكاليه نقابه الاطباء مع
الاحتلال وكانت مشكله النقابه الاطباء
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه وكان تطور هذا
العمل لحتى اصبحت مواجهه شامله في قطاع
غزه اشترك فيها الكل الوطني وما زلت اذكر
كيف كنا ننسق مع الشيخ احمد ياسين مع
الحركه الوطنيه ومع حركه فتح ومع اليسار
الفلسطيني للمواجهه اغلقت المحلات وكان
هناك اضرابات وكان هناك مواجهات وما زلت
اذكر في ذلك اليوم عندما كان هناك مواجهه
مع الاحتلال وجيش الاحتلال في ذلك اليوم
اعلن لبيان رسمي لمواجهه الاحتلال وانطلقت
مسيرات الجهات وعلى الاثر واقتحم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زلت اذكر في منطقتنا
الشجاعيه اقتحم المسجد الذي تحصلنا فيه
واستشهد احد شباب الشعب الفلسطيني
المقربين من شباب المساجد من عائله حلس ما
زلت اذكره في ذلك اليوم كان هناك مواجهه
مباشره مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على هذه
الخلفيه ما سمي في حينه ثوره المساجد في
82 كانت الحركه الاسلاميه تنتقل رويدا
رويدا في هذا العمل ومواجهه الاحتلال بشكل
بشكل متدرج واعاده الاعتبار للعمل الوطني
الحقيقي ومواجهه الاحتلال ان كان في الفكر
الداخلي او كان في العمل الامني الموجه ضد
الاحتلال وضد العملاء وتطور بعد ذلك رويدا
رويدا حتى اصبح ذروته في السبعه وثمانين
مع انطلاق الانتفاضه الاولى وانطلاق اسم
حماس
بشكل واضح تواصل كان كبير مع مع حماس
الخارج مع الرموز التي كانت خارج غزه
تاثيرهم على على تا تاثرهم بما يجري في
الداخل طبعا انا في تلك الفتره انا يعني
في هذه اللحظه كان عمري انا عشرين سنه 23
سنه كان اعمل في الصفوف الخلفيه
لكن بعد ذلك كان هناك ما علمنا بعد ذلك من
الترابط ما بين الحركه الاسلاميه برا في
الداخل والخارج وفي هذا الاطار لكن قلب
العمل وارسل العمل والانطلاق كان في
الداخل وخاصه احنا عايشناه في المراحل
اللاحقه من الانتفاضه عندما انخرطنا في
صفوفها وقدنا الانتفاضه واعتقلنا بعد ذلك
هل استشعر اليوم اليوم انه ثمه يعني
تصورات مختلف عليها ما بين قيادات حماس
لنشات في الخارج واللي نشات في الداخل
يعني الشعور داخل القطاع مختلف قطعا
الحاجيات
الاولويات الضرورات وما الى ذلك شبك عليه
بلا شك انه في العمل التنظيم احنا كشعب
فلسطيني بشكل عام متواجدين في بيئات
مختلفه وكل بها الى الى ظروف الخاصه نحن
نتفهم البيئه التي يعمل فيها شعبا فلسطين
واخوانه بلا شك الداخل والمتمثل في فلسطين
في الداخل ان كان في الضفه او غزه او 48
له ظروفه في المواجهه المباشر في الخارج
هي بيئه الشعب الفلسطيني في الشتات وهم
ضيوف ونحن ضيوف في كل المجتمعات التي نعيش
فيها هذه لا ظروفها هناك اهداف
ومهمات يقوم بها تقوم بها الحركه
الاسلاميه الحركه وفي الخارج حركه حماس
كما هي الحركات الفلسطينيه الاخرى ان كان
في تاطير للشعب الفلسطيني ان كان في
المحافظه عليه المحافظه على القضيه
الفلسطينيه التواصل مع العالم ومع الامه
لكسب التاييد وكسب الدعم
والتصطيب الشعب الفلسطيني في الداخل لان
مقاومتنا هي في داخل فلسطين وبالتالي في
مهمات وفي مشاريع تقام لكن المه الكبرى
التي نقوم بها كحركه وكشعب وكحركه وطنيه
هي العمل في مواجهه الاحتلال على طريق
التحرير وهذا لا يكون الا في الداخل مع
دعم الخارج ان كان من الامه او من الدول
او الدعم الرسمي او الشعبي وغير ذلك فنحن
نتفهم بلا شك يعني ما يمكن ان يقال ويضخ
في خلافات بين صفوف الحركه بالداخل
والخارج انا اقول انه احنا بلا شك لسنا
نسخه كربون واحده ولكن نحن متفاهمون
ومتفهمون
وموحدون على خيار الحركه مقاومه الاحتلال
تحليل فلسطين هدفنا هو الهدف المشترك كيف
نوحد القنوات والعمل بهذا الاتفاق بهذا
الاتجاه لا خلاف على مقاومه الاحتلال لكن
كفه الداخل بدت تكون ارجح في في مواقع
القياديه اليوم في الحرب الداخل هو الوطن
والخارج هو الضياف وبالتالي الوطن ومن هو
على الوطن تكلفه اكبر يعني تكلفه الداخل
ان كان في الدم
والالم وغير ذلك بلا شك اكبر
الفلسطيني في الخارج يدفع ضريبه الغربه
نحن في الداخل ندفع ضريبه المواجهه مع
الاحتلال مباشره وبالتالي كلما تصاعدت
الحركه الوطنيه والحركه في داخل الحركه
الوطنيه والمقاومه يزيد رصيد الحركه لكل
ابناء الحركه وليس كل ابناء الحركه فحسب
انما لكل الشعب الفلسطيني المشروع حماس
السياسي الدكتور بدا بشكل قوي في مطلع
التسعينيات تزامنا مع مشروع اوسلو كيف اثر
اثرت هذه
يعني هذه خلينا نقول هذا الاختراق الكبير
في مسار القضيه الفلسطينيه على البرنامج
السياسي للحركه اعتقد انه يعني برنامج
حماس يمكن قبل يعني التسعينات مع انطلاقه
الانتفاضه الاولى
وتشكلت العقليه
الحمساويه
الاسلاميه الوطنيه المقاومه على هذا
المشروع تحرير الارض وعوده الانسان بل
مختصر وبالتالي تشكل هذا الامر بالمقاومه
وتط الادوات المقاومه والعمل الوطني
المشترك كان احد رموز واركان هذه الرؤيه
الوطنيه والعمل المجتمع بالشكل الكبير
وحشد الامه وحجز كل الطاقات بلا شك جاء
مشروع اوسلو انا اعتبره قاطع طريق على
المشروع الوطني بالكامل لانه كان المشروع
الوطني مؤمن بانه هذا العدوان يجب ان يزول
فجاء اتفاق اسلموا متوهمين من فعلوه انه
يمكن ان ياخذوا حقا الفلسطينيين وكل
النداءات لم يسمعوه وكل التجارب لم
يسمعوها فقطع الطريق على مواصله الانتفاضه
الاولى لقطف الثمار وبالتالي الانتفاضه
الاولى تحولت من انتفاضه الحجاره المقاومه
الشعبيه الشامله الى مقاومه مسلحه بالقدر
الذي واجهها الاحتلال وبدات في تصاعدها
بشكل كبير وامتلات المعتقدات بالسجون
وبدات الاحتلال يعاني من هذه الانتفاضه
لكن للاسف الشديد موهدا لها بمزيد من
الحوارات وغيره وايهام
تفاوض الفلسطيني والقياده المتنفذه بانه
ممكن تاخذوا حق هذا الاجتهاد الخطيئه قطع
الطريق على مواصله الانتفاضه لذلك عندما
في الالفين عندما شعروا انهم قد فشلوا في
هذا المشروع غض الطرف عن انطلاقه جديده
لانتفاضه الاقصى وبالتالي انخرط فيها
الشعب الفلسطيني بالكامل ابناء السلطه
وابناء حماس وابناء الجهاد وكل شعبه
فلسطيني فاحدثنا تطورا جيدا في هذا
الموضوع لكن للاسف الشديد عاد المتنفذون
في السلطه وقطعوا الطريق على مواصله
الانتفاضه ولكن اثمرت الانتفاضه الثانيه
انتفاضه الاقصى اثمرت عن خروج الاحتلال
بلا قيد وشرط من غزه وبعض مستوطنات شمال
الضفه الغربيه وهذا كان احد الثمار
المباشر لتفاضل لكن حماس عادته وانخرطت في
المؤسسات التي نتجت عن اوسلو وعن عن هذه
العمليه برمتها يعني احنا اولا كانه وصلت
الاستنتاجات التي وصلت لها فتح قبل ذلك
ليس هذا التوصيف المناسب
التوصيف المناسب ان هذه السلطه لم يكن عنا
قرار بانهائها ولمواجهه وهذا الاجتهاد
ليتحمله اصحابه وخط المقاومه بقي قائما
ولم نصطدم مع السلطه وتحملنا الاذى منها
في الفترات الكبيره بعد 96 ما يقرب من
اربع سنوات وحتى تم القضاء على التنظيم
وغيره ولكن بقيت الروح متجدده لكن عندما
ذهبنا للمشاركه في الانتخابات لانه كان
كنا نقرا ان هناك محاوله جديده لانهاء ما
تبقى من الروح الفلسطينيه واعاده تنظيم
صفوف هذا المسار السياسي الموهوم
بالانتخابات مجددا للالتفاف على المقاومه
وعزلها واستمرار هذا وبالتالي عندما اخذنا
قرار المشاركه في الانتخابات كان بهدفين
اثنين الهدف الاول حمايه برنامج المقاومه
الذي اصبح هو البرنامج الاصيل الذي يلتف
عليه عموم الشعب الفلسطيني وقد اثمر دحر
الاحتلال عن قطاع غزه في 2005 فلابد من
المحافظه على التراكم قوه المقاومات
الثاني انه السلطه على مدار وجودها من 94
حتى 2005 11 سنه برز مع عوامل الترهل
والفساد الاداري وغير ذلك مما لفظه الناس
فكنا لابد ان من المشاركه في هذه السلطه
لتصويب وتقويم الخلل الاداري والفساد
الاداري اللي كانوا هذين الهدفين دخلنا
السلطه لا ايمانا باسلو ولا انسجما فيه
وبالتالي احنا كان رئيس الوزراء الاستاذ
اسماعيل عندما اعطاه ابو مازن كتاب
التكليف التزم بمبادئ واطر الحركه التي
التزمها ولم يلتزم
بما اشار له ابو مازن من اتفاقيات وهذا
كان هنا بدات الاشكال ما بين مسارين مسار
اوسلو الحقيقي الذي هو يهدف بشيء ومسار
المقاومه جاءت حركه تمثل حماس وانتخبها
الشعب الفلسطيني المجلس التشريعي وهي
الشرعيه الدستوريه والشرعيه الانتخابيه
والقانونيه وبالتالي بقي المسران مختلفان
هل كانت حماس يعني بصدد التحول من حركه
الى الى الى الى سلطه بشكل اكبر حينما
انخرطت في هذا الموضوع 2006 بالانتخابات
وتشكيل الحكومه وما الى ذلك لا يعني حماس
بقيت حركه حركه مقاومه
ودفعت ببعض قياداتها وكوادرها والمقربين
منها ليشاركوا في الحكم وفي المجلس
التشريعي
لهذين السببين المباشر رئيس الكتله نعم في
2006 ولكننا في كل النقاشاتنا لم نقر يوما
من الايام اي اتفاقيه من اتفاقيه السلطه
ولم نقرؤوس وبالتالي كان الخلاف استراتيجي
في العمل السياسي والعمل المباشر الميداني
لذلك بقيت حماس على مبادئها وافكارها
ورؤيه السياسيه لكن ذهبنا لمقاربات سياسيه
اللي ذهبنا لعمل مقاربات سياسيه تحافظ على
بقاء مسيره المقاومه وحمايه هذا البرنامج
والوصول للنقطه اتفاق كمشروع وطني او نقطه
الالتقاء ما بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وسميناه برنامج الحد الادنى المتفق عليه
الوطني اللي برز عنا وظهر جليا في كلمات
الشيخ احمد ياسين رحمه الله عليه في 88
وتم تثبيت تثبيت ما يمكن اشرنا اليه في
وثيقه الحماس السياسيه 2017 وبالتالي حماس
من يراقبها من يوم من نشاتها حتى اليوم
بقت محافظه على الخط الاصيل لبرنامجها
ورؤيتها السياسيه لكن عملنا مقاربات
سياسيه للوفاق الوطني لامكانيه الانطلاق
ببرنامج مشترك لكن بقيت ايدينا على الزناد
وبقت المقاومه ما ان يتاح فرجه للمقاومه
تنطلق الحركه بكل مكونات كما تلاحظه يتحدث
عن الزناد وما انتجهه في قطاع غزه يعني
الحركه خاضت التجربه السياسيه وكان من
الواضح ان افق هذه التجربه محدود جدا
وحدثت الاشكاليه بعدها بعام وانتهى هذا
المشروع المشروع المطروح سياسيا بينكم
وبين فتحه عبر السلطه الفلسطينيه لكن بعد
ذلك
بدات المواجهات مع اسرائيل سيطره الحركه
بشكل كامل وكانها كانت تعد نفسها لهذه
اللحظه لحظه المواجهه مع تطورت هذه بدات
ضعيفه او محدوده ثم اليوم في اي وضع
الحركه
تحدث من الناحيه من ناحيه قدرتها او
جاهزيتها لمواجهه كبرى مع اسرائيل شوف انا
اريد ان اطمنك يا استاذ علي ولكل
المشاهدين يعني حماس في كل مراحلها قبل
الانتخابات 2006 وبعدها حفظت حفظت على
كانونتها في الثلاثيه في المقاومه وما
يمثل كتاب القسام في منظمتها الامنيه في
منظمتها التنظيميه والحركيه والدعويه بقيت
هذه المسارات لم تمس ولم تختلط بشان
الحكومي
[موسيقى]
ودرع للمقاومه وخلقت معادلات جديده مع
للاحتلال وضد الاحتلال يهاب والاحتلال
ويحسب حسابات كثيره لاي اقتراح اقتراح لها
او كسرها ومن اليوم انا استطيع ان اقول ان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مقدمه حماس وكتائب
القسام قادر على ردع الاحتلال ونموذج سيف
القدس
جاهزون لتكراره في اي لحظه يتوجب الامر
ذلك اذا ما استهدف القدس والاقصى او كان
الاستهداف المباشر لكينونه الشعب
الفلسطيني في الضفه وغزل لذلك احنا
الجاهزيه موجوده للانخراط في العمل
المقاوم فنحن شعب موحد اي مواجهه خطه
خبطها حماس كانت الاصعب والاكثر يعني قسوه
وصعوبه ودقه مع الاحتلال من بين المواجهات
الكثيره التي حدثت هي كل المواجهات صعبه
لانه احنا نواجه من قلب شعب في غزه من بين
اهلنا وشعبنا وهم يلتحفون ونحن ابناء من
التحفه كل مواجهات صعبه ولكن كل مرحله من
مراحل كان لها ظروف خاصه ان كانت في حرب
[موسيقى]
2009 او كانت 2012 او كان 2014 او ما بين
الحروب احنا كنا ناخذ حروب الاساسيه دكتور
الحروب الاساسيه ربما تكون بلا شك الاقصى
كانت
لطولها ولحجم الدمار فيها ولكن خلقت
معادلات مهمه في سيف القدس 2021 نستض ان
نكون كانت الاكثر دراوه بيننا وبين
الاحتلال لكن اوجدت معادله سياسيه
وميدانيه كبيره يعني انا اقصد هل بعد كل
حرب او بعد كل مواجهه كبرى
ترتفع الاثمان اللي ممكن يدفعها الاحتلال
اذا فكر في مواجهه تليها من هنا انا قلت
2021 كانت الاقصى على الاحتلال لان
الاحتلال تفاجا بانه صواريخ المقاومه
وصواريخ القسام من غزه تصل جميع ارض
فلسطين انت عندما تمتلك صاروخ 250 كيلو
يضرب في كل مكان يصل شمال فلسطين ويصل شرق
فلسطين واصل القلب فلسطين يصل قلب القدس
انت عندما تعلن حظر التجوال على الاحتلال
في
تل ابيب هنا وهناك وبالتالي هذه التكلفه
كبيره ولذلك استطيع ان اقول انه كلما زادت
المواجهه كلما زادت التكلفه بلا شك علينا
وعليهم لكن الاحتلال لانه طارئ ولانه لا
يحتمل المعركه في قلبه يكون
اكثر حساسيه في اي مواجهات قادمه
[موسيقى]
الاعتقال الاول متى كان دكتور انا اعتقلت
في ثلاث مرات تقول ثلاث مرات في
اوائل
1980 قلت شهر ونصف ولم يستطع الاحتلال
يعني ان يثبت علي شيئا هذا بفضل الله عز
وجل واعتقلت في 82 ايضا الاعتقالي الثاني
لمده اسبوع وكان اعتقالا قاسيا
بشكل كبير في 82 ولم يستطع الاحتلال بفضل
الله بمعنى التعذيب التعذيب يعني التعذيب
الذي يعني
تحملته في 82
قاسي جدا لدرجه
لكن وصلت الى شرفت على الموت والهلاك يعني
شو كانوا يعني
يهدفون له من عمليه التعذيب هو بده ينتزع
منك اعتراف انضمامك الى الحركه الوطنيه
انضمامك لعمل المقاومه من فضل الله عز وجل
مكثفنا هذه الفتره وثبتنا الله ولم يصد
الاحتلال الانتزاع
الثالث كان في
1991 على اثر طبعا
انضمامي بعد عودتي من الدراسات العليا في
89 بالاردن من الاردن التحق بالحركه
مباشره
بالاعمال الانتفاضه وقياده الحركه ان كان
في منطقتي او ثم اصبحت في قياده الحركه
على مستوى القطاع وكنت مسؤول عن مدينه غزه
في كامله في التنظيم وانخرطنا في متابعه
اعمال الانتفاضه والاعمال التنظيميه
والحركيه على اثر ذلك في ضربه الحركه في
اخر التسعين اعتقلت في هذا التاريخ هم كفي
الاحتلال ثلاث سنوات هذا كان الاعتقال
الاطول هذا الاعتقال اطول نعم وتم تهجير
بعض بعض من اعتقلوا في تلك الفتره في تلك
الفتره طبعا الاحتلال صعد عمليه الابعاد
من الجهاد بالذات بشكل
تم ابعاد مرحلتين في يمكن من
على دفعتين ثم كان الابعاد الكبير في 92
9240 تقريبا الى لبنان الى لبنان وكان
غالبيتهم من حركه حماس مع الاخوه في
الجهاد الاسلامي لكن الحمد لله
بصمودهم ووحدتهم وضع نصب العوده تم عوده
الجميع باستثناء من يعني بقي لظروف امنيه
يعني
ماذا ترك الاعتقال الطويل اعوام ثلاثه
تجارب الاعتقال عاده ماذا تترك في اثر
المنخرطين في عمليات المقاومه الاعتقال
غالبا في الذين يعتقلوا مؤمنين بخيارهم لا
يزيدهم الا صلابه
يزيد قناعه بان هذا الاحتلال الى زوال
يزيد من قناعه
بمواجهه الاحتلال يعطيهم قوه في مواجهه
الاحتلال في فترات الاعتقال بطريقه اخرى
الروح الوطنيه تتعاظم اكثر واكثر والبيئه
من حول هذا الاسير المعتقل تصبح حاضنه
لمشروع المقاومه بشكل عام وحاضنه لهذا
الاسير ولمن حوله لانه بلا شك معاناه
الاسير وظروف الاعتقال والمعامله يعانيها
يشاهدها من حوله من اهله اقاربه والاسره
القريبه وبالتالي هذا ينعكس على على
الاسره وعليه رفض للاحتلال ولفظ له بكل
هذه المعاني وانا اعتقد انه معظم من اللي
دخلوا السجون يعني كانوا يحتملون هذه
النفسيه وهذه وبالتالي هؤلاء الشباب
يخرجون من السجن اكثر قوه ومضاءا لانه لا
خيار امامه الا موجود هذا لاننا نقاتل
الاحتلال ونقام الاحتلال عن قناعه وعن
عقيده وعن دين ان هذا الاحتلال هو يسلبنا
ارادتنا يسلبنا حريتنا يسلبنا ارضنا
مقدساتنا ولسنا بدعا من البشر
فضلا عن هذه الارض مقدسه ومباركه يامرون
وطنيه وديننا وعقيدتنا ان ندافع عنها ربما
اكثر مما يدافع عن اي انسان اخر عن وطني
2007 استهدف دكتور نعم من قبل الاحتلال
صحيح لم تنجح العمليه لم تنجح لكن استشهد
مجموعه من عائلتي من اخواني وابناء اخوتي
في ذلك الاستهداف تبقى قصف المنزل
في 2007 في مايو ايار 2007 استهدف ديوان
العائله
واستشهد مجموعه من سبعه من عائلتي واحد
جيراننا منهم اثنين من اخوتي واربعه من من
ابناء اخوتي وابن ابناء
واثنين من ابناء عمومتي وابناء فهذول
استشهدوا سبعه في ذلك اسامه استشهد ايضا
الابنه
مشهد في 2008
فيما سمي بالمحرقه وكان في عمل المقاوم ضد
الاحتلال واستشهد في ذلك المعركه رحمه
حمزه من كتاب القسام نعم حمزه كان هو
مسؤول
[موسيقى]
ضرب الصواريخ والهونات في منطقه الشيعه
وكانوا المسؤول الاول كان اول شهيد من
ابنائك كان اول شهيد من ابنائي نعم حمزه
اي اي ترتيب
الاكبر البكر اسامه في 2014 تهدف منزل
عائله خير الحياه 2014 استهدف الاح المنزل
الذي كان في العائله ابني وعائلته وزوجتي
وابناء الاخرين لكن قدرا ابناء التوائم
الاخرين كانوا موجودين في خارج البيت عند
مكان اخر عند اهلي فاستهدوا في البيت دون
انذار في ذلك البيت قصه يكون في انذار
للمنازل في بعض الاحيان الاحتلال للاسف
ينذر البيوت التي لا يوجد فيها شيء بس
يريد ان ندمرها لكن عندما يكون لديه هدف
ما يقصف بدون الهدف انت واسرتك كان الهدف
انا وابني بالدرجه هو اعلن بعد ذلك ان
الهدف ابني بالدرجه الاساسيه
اسامه لانه هو كان على راس عملي في
المقاومه وفي كتاب القسام
فاستهدف استشهد هو وزوجته وثلاثه من
ابنائه ولدان وبنت ثلاثه من ابناء اسامه
ومن ابنائك من استشهد في هذا ابني هو
اسامه وكانت زوجتي وولده
وبنته الكبيره عبد الرحمن النجا عبد
الرحمن
بن موسى مكان عمره ثلاث سنوات ودمر البيت
في هذا لا يوجد استثناء قيادي في حماس
انهم كانهم بمن عن الضرر والالام اولا
احنا نتشرف اننا جزء من ابناء الشعب واننا
نعيش بينهم بالامهم واحزانهم وافراحهم ولو
جئت تعمل احصائيه لقيادات حماس الاولى
الذين فقدوا ابنائهم او اقاربهم فهم
بالعشرات يعني ان كانوا في البعد السياسي
او البعد الدعوي او الامني او الحكومه او
غير ذلك حدث ولا حرج هناك عشرات من قيادات
حماس الاولى فقدت ابنائها وبعض استشهد مع
عائلتي وابنائي مثل الدكتور نزار ريان مثل
الاستاذ سعيد الصيام رحمه الله عليه مثل
اخونا ابو خالد الزهار قصه بيت واستشهد
ابنه وبعد ذلك ابنه فل ابو اسامه دخان
وعدد كبير من قيادات الحركه الاولى
تاثيرا لذلك دكتور عند الناس عند الاخرين
من خارج يعني ابناء الحركه حينما تذهبون
حينما يسقط شهداء من من شك ان احنا
مطمئنون اننا ملتحفون مع ابناء شعبنا
واننا جزء منهم وجزء منا بلا شك نلمس ان
المواطن الفلسطيني يشعر انه قاده المقاومه
هم منهم هذا ابن شهيد وهذا ابن الشهيد هذا
اخوه شهيد وهذا اخوه شهيد ونلمس ذلك
مباشره يعني على مستوى الشخص مستوى
اخواننا عندما نذهب نواسي الناس الناس
ترانا ونحن نحمل على اكتافنا ابنائنا
واخواننا
وابناء اخواتنا وابناء اعمامنا
لا يعني لانه الاحتلال لم يفرق الاحتلال
مفرق ونحن عندما نقود مشروع مقاومه الذي
يريد ان يقود مشروع مقاوم اذا لم يكن في
المقدمه فليتنحن هذا المكان الذي يريد ان
يقود مشروع مقاومه لابد ان يكون جاهز
بالتضحيه بنفسه وماله وولده والا
اهلا لذلك اليوم انت في موقع القياده لهذه
الحركه التي تقود المواجهه مع دوله
الاحتلال ماذا ترى ماذا ترى في قادم
الايام ماذا ترى في في هذه المعركه
الطويله والمعقده مع دوله الاحتلال بكل
اطمئنان
انا مطمئن كثير من المراقبين اننا نقترب
لحسم الصراع مع هذا العدو فان بوادر ضعف
الكيان الصهيوني تبدو يوما بعد يوم
والاسباب متعدده صيانه اليوم يتمدد
بالتطبيع ولكن بدات دوده السوس تنخر في
هذا الكيان الصهيوني ان كان في الحاضنه
الدوليه او كان في بنيته الداخليه او كان
في قناعات الامه والشعب الفلسطيني
الاحتلال لا يتهدد وجوده الا اذا امن
الشعب المحتل بقضيته واليوم شو عمل
الفلسطيني كل يوم يتعزز ايمانه بمقاومه
الاحتلال وانت ترى ذلك في الضفه الغربيه
وفي غزه وفي 48 لانه الاحتلال اسرائيل
اليوم يريد ان يحسم المعركه وما دام اقترب
من حسم المعركه اذا ستحسم المعركه لصالح
شعبنا اذا توجد مقاومه
رحيل الاحتلال
تعالوا ليخرج هذا الاحتلال ولو متدرجا من
ارض فلسطين اين المجتمع الدولي الذي يريد
نحن نؤمن بضروره خروج الاحتلال من فلسطين
كل فلسطين لكن ان يخرج على دفعتين جيد
ليخرج اولا من الضفه الغربيه يبدا كان
خروجها نعم يلي يخرج من الضفه الغربيه
كاملا بلا قيد وشرط ثم نكمل المسير نحن
وابناء واحفادهم لذلك نحن مطمئنون ان ما
زلنا مقتنعين بخيار المقاومه وندفع بكل
اتونها وفي الامه من يحتضن ويدعمنا من من
دول ومن شعوب ومن غير ذلك حتى وان وجد
الاحتلال الحاضنه الدوليه الظالمة هنا
وهناك لكن شعب مؤمن بقضيته يحتضن المقاومه
وعدوه ينخر السوس في في بنيانه وداخله
باعتقاد اننا على الطريق الصواب باذن الله
وخاصه ايضا اضافه ان الاجتهاد في تسويه
الصراع الفلسطيني الصهيوني فشلت فشلا
ذريعا للامانه اليوم شو عملوا فلسطيني
موحد على ذلك بكل اطيافه المقاومه في
الشعب الفلسطيني اليوم بكل اطيافها حماس
وفتح وحتى بعض ابناء الاجهزه الامنيه
والجهاد الاسلامي والشعبيه والمواطن
العادي ملتحم ومتضامن ضد هذا الكيان دكتور
خليل الحياض المكتب السياسي ورئيس مكتب
العلاقات العربيه والاسلاميه ونائب رئيس
الحركه في قطاع غزه ضيفنا في الحلقتين هذه
والحلقه الماضيه شكرا جزيلا لك حياكم الله
تسلم مشاهدينا الكرام شكرا لكم وانتم على
طيب المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع
المقبل في لقاء جديد دمتم بخير والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
متى يستسلم الفلسطيني
لماذا لانه يوجد عدوان على غزه علينا ان
نفعل كل ما بوسنا لكي
نرفع راياتنا
[موسيقى]